if you are planning your holiday
celebrations make sure they are clean
and bright with clean carpet tile
upholstery rugs and air ducts from zero
rez and joining me now is ben mckee one
of the mckee brothers who owns and
operates zero res las vegas welcome back
ben hey good to see you look very nice
for the holidays dressing up i know
they're coming up really soon so we got
to get prepared and that's with one of
the first questions i have with the
holidays coming up everyone gathers you
got friends you got family coming in and
you want to have your home ready what do
people need to know about getting ready
for the holidays well first and foremost
your in-laws are coming into town and
they're going to judge you on your
carpets and they're flooring so you've
got to call zebo res that's a great time
to clean too you're going to get really
fast dry times this time of year
and plus just for the holidays it's
great to be clean and hygienic for
everyone coming over and you do want to
have a clean home for them you may have
people coming in with
immune issues allergies and
tell us about the zero res difference
how can you make carpet so much cleaner
than the other guys well what's crazy is
carpet cleaning hasn't changed for
nearly 80 years people are still
cleaning with soaps and surfactants zero
res our technology has eliminated the
need for those products and it leaves
your carpet soft to the touch and
actually helps your carpets stay cleaner
longer without any weird odors or
anything associated with it that's one
thing i noticed the first time i had you
guys to my house and
there was no crunchiness which i loved
and then they dried really really fast
usually you have to wait like a day and
it was like within hours it's crazy how
fast it dries and it's because we have
the right equipment coupled with the
right technology and we have a crew
that's properly trained on what they're
doing not just the technical side but
also on providing great customer service
i want to talk about that customer
service a little bit because you're
right it's unparalleled the customer
service you get from xero rest tell us
what people can expect when someone from
zero res comes to their house
we're going to come in and treat your
home like it's yours we're not going to
come in and ding up your walls we're
going to put up corner guards
and plus like if you just go look at our
reviews i think we're probably the most
recommended carpet cleaner in las vegas
we have nearly 6 000 reviews on google
with 4.9 stars it's it's incredible
and we love the las vegas community and
we couldn't do it without you well let's
see let's see zero resin action here
this is my favorite part this is when we
take this dirty dirty carpet
and i'm just going to give it a big ol
swipe here we got to get this on camera
okay check this out what's crazy
mercedes is this is strictly our zr
water technology there's no soaps
there's no surfactants involved this is
strictly the power of water and you can
notice right away a huge cleaning
difference
i think that's one swipe you and you
guys go over it multiple times all of
the stuff that is coming up in that this
is what you're breathing this is what
you're walking on with your bare feet it
is your carpet's actually the largest
air filter in your home so it's
collecting dander bacteria pollen all
sorts of nasty things
you need a higher professional cleaner
to come in and help remove those
contaminants now if that's not enough to
make you want to have zero res in your
home you guys actually have a great
special going on right now we do right
now cowabunga bay we partnered with them
we have a festival of lanterns coming up
so if you get your home and your
business clean we're gonna give you some
tickets to that yeah it's really cool
and the prices you you can't beat them
give xerorez a call at
702-840-3333 or visit them online
xerorez lasvegas.com and again that
special offer it's their november
special you can get your carpet cleaned
as low as 35 dollars per room plus get
two free tickets to the festival of
lanterns it's going to be so cool over
at
cowabunga bay minimums apply thank you
guys so much jillian i'll send it over
to you